jesse
right now you have four wins under your
belt you've got twenty thousand dollars
in your pocket you're fighting for the
five grand
but being that this is your fifth
competition if you win you will also
receive that bonus of ten thousand
dollars do you wanna pick the weapon or
do you wanna pick the forge welding
technique
i want the weapon all right what are you
thinking
i'm thinking the pair of pugio daggers
holy cow what a bold choice
the pugio was a popular sidearm in
second and third century rome gladiators
were known to battle with two pugio one
in each hand these close-quarter combat
weapons featured a wide leaf-shaped
blade to inflict deep lethal wounds upon
an enemy both on battlefield and inside
the walls of the coliseum however the
pugio is most well known as the weapon
used to murder julius caesar
john you've got a choice to make what
forge welding technique do you want to
use to build your daggers let's go with
canister and we're going to have to use
some bicycle chain in it bicycle chain
in canister damascus all right very very
tall order on the plate today so good
luck stay sharp your time starts now
because this is my fifth battle i'm
definitely a little bit tired i've hit
that bottom plateau in terms of energy
the only way i can go is up i used to
forge out chef's knives at home in
batches of two or three so this is a
pretty comfortable zone for me
i think my canister is up to temperature
now i think it's the perfect time to
bring them over to the squaring dice and
start setting those welds right now i
have them all forged to shape fit the
dimension just wanna get them ready for
e-tree now
it's time for liquench so i decided to
do one at a time
oh look at a quench
the temperature of my first blade looked
perfect now it's time to put blade two
in the fire
all right jesse's got two blades
quenched
it went perfectly there were no warps in
either blade it's time to grind these
blades to final dimension i slap on a
fresh 36 grit and just start going ham
but there's still a few things that i
need to do in this round include finish
shaping the handle and then sharpening
it i leave myself a lot of time to
sharpen these blades because i don't
want to run out of time and have one
edge unsharpened
so the idea that i've got is that i'm
gonna forge the two knives out of one
billet and i'm gonna stretch out the
tang in the middle
and then i'll cut those in two so after
i've got them ground now it's time to
heat treat
out of the oil it looks good i think
i've got what i want that's gonna work
and then i go to the grinder
that's not great
the second blade i noticed a t-lamp on
the edge
i am concerned that another could show
up while i grind but i think i've still
got enough width and so now i'm just
going to work back out
i now have to assemble these two handles
it is going to be a big challenge all
the way around i know i have to find a
handle because the clock marches on
everything seems to be just right but i
glance i'm seeing i've used up better
than an hour so i know i've got to keep
moving on
it's a very complex handle i know that i
have a lot of moving parts in this i
know i'm going to have to make sure
everything fits properly with it what
john's doing is a great idea but it's
very very time consuming it's not an
easy process but i do get them inset
some
after i get the pommel glued on minutes
to the grinder
it looks like a potato on a stick um it
doesn't look great and i need to get
this shaped into something that is
functional what john's got going on his
handle it kind of almost looks like a
dog chew bone i still need to sharpen
the blade i get it etched i'm racing the
clock right now and i don't have time to
make mistakes today
five
four
three
two
one placements driving machines put down
your tools this battle is over
bladesmith spoken our strength test the
armor stab and slash
jesse you're up first you ready to go
i'm ready to go i know you love going
first yep
uh
all right jesse you survived good job
uh your blades look great i like the
symmetry on these
i mean they look like a matched pair
everything's tight everything's smooth
your edges
are still good you do have a few flat
spots
but there's not enough there where i can
catch a nail on it
the biggest issue i have is the handles
they have no grip to them whatsoever
enough so one of the chops i actually
caught a knuckle because the knuckle
slipped up
some contouring would have made it a lot
easier to hold on to them but otherwise
great job thank you
it's always fun being the second guy
right here why not
you ready to go absolutely all right
let's do it
uh
all right john you survived
gotta be happy about that
you got some glinting on the edges
nothing i'm really catching on
the biggest problem i have the
contouring you have on there is
basically the exact opposite of what i
said about jessie's they're not sliding
anywhere but they're not comfortable at
all
but overall they held together and
nothing came loose edges survived good
job thank you
that ears of the forge
this is the sharpness test the banner
slice
just here first you ready for this i'm
ready all right
[Music]
all right jesse let's talk about your
matching hujio daggers here that's a
beautiful match set they're quite
identical very close to that now your
edge your edges cut nicely and overall
your weapon
you'll cut
john your turns are you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
all right jon talk about your pujo
daggers here your edges are sharp it's
just that it's got a grinder here that's
not razor sharp so when cutting with
this there are some areas in this where
it just got snagged with the blade and
it does rip a little bit
but overall sir your puju daggers you
will cut thank you
all right gentlemen after eight hours of
furious battle where you guys built your
pugio daggers out of bicycle chain
canister damascus it is coming down to a
final decision only one of you can come
out of here on top for the title of
glady to the forge jesse if you win that
will be your fifth win and you will have
35 000 in your pocket
now john if you win you'll stop his
winning streak get your first glider to
the forge title and check for five
thousand dollars in the opportunity to
go forward into the next battle
our judges have discussed your blades
and they made a final decision
today's gladiator forge is
jesse you have done it again that is
five total wins john you brought us a
good pair of blades but unfortunately
they didn't come out on top and jay's
gonna tell you why
john you did a great job out there you
should definitely proud of yourself we
sure as i enjoyed watching you work
but at the end of the day
the inner grinds on your pugio daggers
weren't as sharp as your competitors as
we saw during the sharpness test
and
you had a great idea for the handle but
it kind of went south so that's why
we're sending you home
john there's no question you're talented
i know you had your competitor here
worried for a little bit unfortunately
you didn't come out on top today at this
point i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor this is
just one more learning experience take
your education and move to the next
thing jesse you are a five-time champion
you got another check for five grand and
a bonus of ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you
so right now i gotta ask again do you
have enough energy to go back in the
forge and fight out another battle put
me in coach
i love it all right man i have five
titles i'm not ready to give up the seat
anytime soon
you